good boys it's about three good kids
these are good kids yeah these are these
are good you know what's funny cuz he
knows controversy kids this is too much
kids are doing I said honestly this was
the type of kid we didn't know what we
were talking about but we was talking
about so much random stuff that we
didn't understand it was even worse than
cuz you're not now they got funnels of
stuff you know we just had like you guys
have one friend we have freaky parents
they had like the scramble e-channel oh
I mean it had like it hasn't porn on it
but it's also crazy yet see anybody so
for years we didn't know what body parts
went with you know they because it was
like Picasso penis here around and that
messed me up a lot really that's it
that's real talk
yeah let me good its is what I love
about good boys is though is it was just
dope to do a funny movie like I know a
lot of times comedies I'm not sick
companies are not funny no more but it's
been so really it's it mess yes it was
bad comedies
yeah movies and this was just really
really funny and yeah I hope happy you
did well you know I was like okay good
grams
yeah we have a clip here from good boys
anything we need to know for this scene
no I don't know I don't even know what
clip they gave you I bet there's boys in
it yeah
and I bet they're pretty good let's take
a look who's Anya and soda don't tell my
parents you gave me this we're getting a
divorce
everything goes stay the same you
promised well we still watch this is SDV
yes of course that's our favorite show
it's a family show except now you're
gonna see it on to two different TVs you
know in two different houses so you have
to watch the episode twice twice phone
me your mama no we still best friends
right you got a comedy special coming
out - yeah
HBO comedy but I do want to shut up yeah
I love redish she is so funny it was
doing this but yeah yeah HBO comedy
special November 23rd shot in LA I know
you're very busy but thanks for making
time for don't tell jokes or just do
politics now I like the way this is set
up this is like a really I didn't drink
the water - cuz I always won about the
cup water you know we don't even know
what's in there if the person from like
if you don't drink it it'll be there on
Monday yeah that's water Matt Damon
didn't drink
he was here a couple of days ago well
make sure I get the word out low rels
HBO comedy special live in Crenshaw
debuts November 23rd good boys is
available now on digital and on blu-ray
November 12th and you should check that
out lil rel Howery thank you so much
you're always
[Applause]